if you show their pictures or call their
names in public you run the risk of
being arrested they are shouting their
names
Nuria Gilman and samia's aksha to
teachers who lost their jobs in the
aftermath of last year's failed coup
attempt
they've been on hunger strike in protest
since March the two of them used to come
here to the human rights Monument which
you can see behind me now it remains
sealed off to keep protesters away but
the demonstrations haven't stopped
others are taking to the streets to
express this solidarity the two teachers
were detained in May they are in jail
just like thousands of others but people
have not forgotten them the same
location this week the police are
getting prepared the protesters come
here every day and every day it's the
same procedure the protesters shout the
names of the detained teachers and the
police swiftly disperse the crowd Maria
and Sami have become symbols of
resistance against authoritarian rule in
Turkey we are meeting Ezra she Sam his
wife and says that she too has not eaten
in months
and my husband and Nuria started a
hunger strike 188 days ago they chose
this form of protest to make sure that
their voices are heard the manner of
their arrest was illegal so I went on a
hunger strike to to protest against this
illegal process and add my voice to
theirs as robberies that it's just a
matter of time before she's also
imprisoned but despite that she's
positive about the fact that a trial for
her husband and Nuria is about to begin
where is Amy
I hope Maria and semi will be released
this case has no foundation we want
justice to be done properly we want our
jobs back what we want is quite simple I
think it should be possible so original
Ezra shows us pictures of her life
beef
for the coup attempt last year she had
just married the love of her life she
says but all of a sudden everything
changed one day we woke up and found
we'd been suspended from our jobs then
another day we discovered we'd been
fired without any explanation but we've
nothing to do with the group that was
behind the coup attempt but the
government sees things differently it
accuses Samiha Nuria of being members of
a terrorist group